do you think President Trump ever ever
watches our show our show this show no
no no I mean apparently just watches Fox
and Friends yeah that's what I've heard
he just watches Fox and Friends and that
gave me an idea I want to do just a
quick experiment okay Billy do me a
favor could you roll the Fox and Friends
graphic please okay
now maybe maybe if he's flipping around
and he just saw that maybe President
Trump might watch our show
look that's kind of pathetic you think
it's showing a cheap graphic is enough
to get the president to watch this show
hello juiciest rub
yes hello mr. president thanks for
calling in to the show my pledge your
love what you've done with yeah thank
you thank you very much
we here at Fox and Friends love it yeah
yeah but I have to tell you I don't know
she's right here we have the hot blonde
okay so we have a lot to talk about
syrup which of the good guys here like
better this one sir are you holding
different ties up to the phone of course
that I'm not an idiot
I'm holding them up to the TV then in
that case I like that one
me too okay good night I played all the
biggest jobs
Rocketman ms-13 wicked the crowd went
crazy I really think I could win this
election yes sir you you already won the
election you're the president you're the
president Wow Wow
you know what I've seen you see that
that's why you're my favorite news
channel you're not fake dude you're
better than fake dude you're like fake
fake dude I don't follow sir what's fake
fake news well you ever see a woman with
big fake boobs and you know they're fake
because they're so big I guess yeah sure
okay so your show is like fake boobs
that don't look baked until you're
really close but then it's too late
because you've got an erection and go
and already paid for godsake
mr. president let's about the big news
story okay the really big news story
yeah it is big The Big Bang Theory
ending after twelve seasons what a run
congratulations sir that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about Paul
Manafort being found guilty of bank and
tax fraud Michael Cohen pleading guilty
and saying you ordered him to pay hush
money to two women totally agree Steve
NFL players should all right sir people
are describing yesterday as the darkest
day for the American presidency this
Watergate hey you're saying Paul
Manafort Michael Cohen our fake news no
Watergate never happened Nixon wasn't
even president right lost the election
in 70 CUDA Bret Michaels he lost to Bret
Michaels
mr. president I have news for you take
the graphic away take it away
I am Conan O'Brien we tricked you wait
wait wait Steve Doocy
of Boxford friend just coded O'Brian no
I'm Conan O'Brien your CD no sir I
myself I'm Conan O'Brien please let me
get a closer look it oh you're that tall
redheaded chick you're a 3/4 on a good
day
that guy's wicked
you